hello everybody my name is markiplier
welcome back to let's play knock-knock
or should I say welcome back to this
horribly haunted house okay oh we are
starting to learn the strategy I'm
starting to learn what's needed to
survive in this really messed up world
and oh look I think the the sound is not
doing it anymore okay cool all right
though the weird sound I think that
might have actually been a bug but what
why haven't I looked in here for so long
I don't know why haven't you I don't
even think you're in a real real world
hey you guys here thumping so you need
to turn off the lights when you go out
of rooms because the only way that you
can see the monsters in the darkness is
if they are in the darkness cuz you
can't really see him in the light it
completely blocked him out but they
don't stop existing hello uh-huh a tiny
thingy thank you sir
did some time out of that one a little
bit of just a little bit of help okay oh
crap
so anyway the important thing is to not
let myself get trapped that is what I
don't need to do the long as I stay
alive another time in thingy oh boy I'm
gonna die on it I'm gonna die he closes
his eyes and he opens it and something
appears nowhere to hide though turn that
out okay nothing so far do I even want
to go downstairs
alright let's go
okay what does that mean what did you do
what did you do I don't know what that
means when you do that does that mean a
monster enters the house at that
location so what happened okay great
okay oh no oh that's right bye nunu
let's go down I don't know why go down
let's go down
oh wait wasn't this oh no there's a dead
end
oh no oh no oh no don't see me you don't
see jack make some stuff make some stuff
oh how is that gonna help where are you
man oh it does know where I am that's
why I'm gonna hide like a bow shop house
key can't see me can't see me bro can't
see bro I'm not
no hello friend losing time but that's
okay I got plenty stocked up don't look
at me I can't hide from you in fact I
just did thanks baby
aha what okay
yay hey four times I'm getting good at
this game I'm getting good yes yes yes
all the way baby
Oh a little bit over come on baby come
on hey here here make up something what
the hell is that Amy oh it's done
all right oh I'm real in this game this
game is really fun too
guys you've got if you don't want this
if you would just want to watch this fun
you should play this game alone get up
to three hours before sunrise say this
to yourself three times I didn't forget
anything
walk through your darkened house and
turn on the light in each room go back
to the room you've started in close your
eyes try to focus on the first thing
that comes to mind
if you imagine a face that being will
come to live in your house I want to
play that game play that game
ha ha ha ah so cool I really like this
game it's really cool you guys I'm super
excited about playing it it's like
awesome ok now this if this is the real
world
where did the diary go clearly remember
putting it under my pillow don't get it
where could I have hidden it my memory
didn't used to deceive me like this all
this is rather strange no matter what I
have to find it in media tell or I won't
be able to work tomorrow
what he looks more like of a kid in
those last ones
okay there's it okay there's a time
thing over there got to find the diary
pieces my old man gave me this diary
when I was first learning how to write
he said that I would write my entire
life down in it and that with the last
page of the notebook my life would end
as well that's rather sinister was the
last in our family who was fond of
speaking in metaphors I was very young
then and took his words literally I
wanted to live a long life so I rationed
the pages I wrote only mine my smallest
handwriting rarely and briefly became a
habit but after a while I forgot his
words for some reason they've come back
to me now they unsettled hey pick at the
dot idea all right if you say so man I
don't even know it's not even daylight
is it like for some reason the Sun comes
up and then he totally forgets
everything okay I got the time here no
no no no use it there we go although I
don't need know if I need to use it here
I don't know something is getting closer
from the other side I have don't worry
what do you mean oh the other side is in
where you were before
know that you know I don't want to I
need to find the notebook pages that's
what I need to do
isn't that what I need to do fix the
light man
oh I guess I can cuz I have to go
outside now I'm so busy during the day I
have to take samples of everything here
I have to check on the composition the
soil also the air water fauna vocoder
thing okay well let's go do that why
shan't we
I don't recall ever seeing daylight my
friend whoa whoa whoa who are you what
what
what what
oh my god
okay
I saw a little girl from time to time I
see things that simply cannot be
sometimes I even see new stars in the
sky but I don't record that in my
archives and reports
it's simply depression but maybe it is
something even worse they say it's
called somnolence and it can even lead
to some Nabu lism but this too shall
pass
what what do you mean you I saw a little
girl there I don't know what happened
yep got a little papaya oh I didn't
dance sorry dance prematurely hey Latoya
oh okay
I know some people apparently like that
but I bet a lot of people probably hate
you doing that okay so I didn't even
know there was anything out here to find
oh well there's my house I guess I
didn't know it was right there I could
have missed that very easily
oh boy back into the dream world where
the monster fly oh it's so cool it's
like a two-part thing I'm he tries to
piece together reality in the other
world and this one he just tries to
survive uh okay hang on
okay that's the layout of the house
looks like it goes up more than down so
let's get started shall we
I'm really glad that sound bug isn't
happening when I was sneaking hey what
can i I'm trying to fix it
wait I can't there we go okay sorry
what's the wrong button I guess okay all
right imagine something good man give me
something good come on our bed remember
now someone very small lived here like a
child or that's boxer that was boxing
let's mister Bo hey we don't like this
place I don't like the darkness imagine
something good what's with the eyes on
the floor weird come on man okay
telescope they are real but not as they
appear you see them like that because
you're in a state of somnolent
about me how can these pages be here why
are they told you I don't like this at
all
did someone get into the room while I
was asleep and steal the diary maybe I
have to check the entire house again I
really neglected it if you say something
what are you what are you you don't what
wait what what what happened the air is
thick what does that mean
what was that is that not a normal
monster I was at something else I've no
idea what so confused oh thanks Hey
what okay what do we got buddy friend
ahahahaha time my greatest ally oh it's
so quiet that is nearby nearby come on
come on come on come on what's in here
that's it Klose lee min ba Lu time Oh No
thank you girl go down Oh does it end oh
no oh no oh no oh no the denim hello
give me the blade I'd like a hiding
place you dick makeup hiding place
Oh balls Oh balls
Oh Bo
you thought about it and how it is
inside oh yeah why thanks for the advice
lady do what I didn't do anything
Oh what the hell it's an eye and what's
this is it a hole in the wall or am I
just seeing things
what of course I'm only dreaming again
TV to prove once the light is on this
will all disappear what wait I got an
achievement through the looking-glass
what where am I what did I do
where am I now long periods of isolation
are harmful to the psyche tired mind
distorts the perception of reality I
have to snap out of it I feel like
something eerie is happening to my home
oh really
you mean the monsters and the eyes in
the wall and the wherever held you went
I don't even have a timer anymore are
like going oh I see their doors here
whoa what what happened what ah what
happened
I went back to the same place I went in
a circle ah man you mean that guy go
through all that again
ah but I almost made it through the
night ah balderdash
damn it damn it damn lit daddle it
deadly ah damn Lee
I guess I shouldn't have gone in the
hole or something or maybe I got
something out of that don't really know
just try to survive the night
what oh come on you said you were done
open it up man gotta go there are things
here things do you don't want to see I
need to find time accelerators yeah I
can feel that someone was here recently
there's a lip shaped stain on the door
lock as if someone kissed my door with a
clay card know what that's only a little
weird don't worry about that that's only
a little weird I hear a rumble in the
darkness I hear a rumble who is that a
hidey hole good keep that in mind what
was that lose something on the ground
didn't know what that was time yes thank
you I need time I need to get through
this to get through the night so I don't
waste good Oh turn the light off Oh what
what happened what what happened let's
go what's going is something in the
house did something arrive I think
something spawned imagine something good
in here
I'm good give me something good
everything is what it as it was but
still it's slightly off somehow what's
changed or have I just been too
overwhelmed lately I can't keep anything
straight my memories going well I don't
know man
your thing let's go another hidey-hole
okay though don't need that from now
that's bricked up apparently okay
nothing in here no time can you give me
a time I'm like very anxious guys um ah
that's right nearby Oh turn off no no no
no no no no no no what was it is there
actually something there Heidi
don't hide no hide I don't close that
door opening this is probably a mistake
but whatever I don't have time to dick
around here where did you come from
ah oh my holy crap hide
yes I mean no okay no need no need for
what no need for what this guy is messed
up guys you got a messed up life
messed up life whoa whoa I'm not I'm not
going in that I'm not gonna don't tell
me not to I'm not gonna because he's
waste whoa what happened everything
shook what wow what happened here
something is telling me I shouldn't even
try to uncover it I think you should I
saw a box Addison what happened
reported oh where am I now can one give
me a time thing please time thing ah
what is that doesn't help me ventilation
system for the house all right whatever
it
okay that's still on have I been here
before I don't know I keep getting
zipped around my own house these are
confusing oh that's right above me oh
let me see if I can turn this light on
this looks like an interesting room come
on come on come on okay imagine
something good bougar up time can't use
it when the lights off because give me
time come on come on baby
give me time I don't have any place to
hide in here so
where's the boo-boo boy I just got this
face permanently sticking came in where
no no no soon if nobody died
oh god I don't want that turn it up dawn
oh my god oh god damn it what it's
inside me or what oh I thought that
killed me but it set my time back quite
a bit
oh damn it oh I thought it was gonna
kill me
I thought uh-oh and I lost so much time
oh good another one fine whatever I
don't care
whatever whatever I I lost a lot okay
I'm not opening that door I know that's
bad news
I'm not even gonna bother when something
comes a knock knocking don't open the
damn door police that's no place to hide
all right I'm gonna open it cuz I got
someplace to hide now
someone there over there don't see
anyone don't see anyone missing the
point I'm missing the point what is the
point
what's this incredible point you're
trying to make besides being a do not
what do not what turn on this light do
not do that okay I guess I checked most
of the house now is there something up
there okay all right all right that's
fine can be inside if so long as I get a
chance to go away okay Oh
hide oh there's a time thing there I
want the time thing I want the time
thing oh oh I hide here no not up here
you thought about it and hmm what is
down here it's down here that's you time
thing damn it do you say time thing so
let me win so give me the dawn the still
get me the dawn will it will it will it
will it yes one more little mark good
come on come on go
Hey ha ha I don't know who you are you
that little girl that I found in the
woods voice mysterious voice OH
oh man this game is stressful this game
is a heart attack and a half something
new this is a game which should be
played in the dark sit in front of the
window and close your eyes imagine that
something new appeared in the ink the
dark inky darkness beyond the window say
this to yourself it's there I simply did
it didn't see it before now repeat this
until you feel that someone is watching
you through the window then leave the
room why would I play that game
ah alright let me just get to the next
house in a month why is this house on
the other side of the line
does that mean that this house is on the
other side okay I don't have time I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
keep going I gotta I'm out of time I'm
Way out of time
so this game is so cool you guys have
got to play this for yourself it's
freaking amazing
play it seriously it's worth it it's
only ten bucks
play it all right thank you all so much
for watching click the annotation for
more videos that I've done and as always
I will see you in the next video bye bye
it should just be the one in the
building got a trick to make it
screenshot from here to there one more
time good okay thunders bro
- crow to be stopped by Slendy
I'm gonna mention ugliness it
I'm hoping I do okay
a limit to my sprint which is only nice
feature
Slendy that means because employment
not hard